imagine commuting a thousand feet above
traffic fifty years ago during the
Golden Age of helicopter travel you
could until a tragic accident in 1977
brought that era to a close but with new
technology on the horizon a new age of
airborne commuting could be just around
the corner ever since the first
skyscrapers shot upward visions of New
York City's future showcased convenient
access to the skies those visions were
realized in 1953 when a helicopter
airline called New York Airways
established a schedule of routes
carrying passengers between Manhattan's
Riverside heliports and New York City's
airports in a fleet of repurposed Boeing
and Sikorsky military helicopters for as
little as five dollars you could hop on
one of their 20 seat shuttles and be it
your departure gate within 10 minutes at
its peak New York Airways served over a
half million passengers a year with
dozens of daily scheduled flights we
always flew past the Statue of Liberty
on the way to Newark to give the
passengers and canoe that and it was it
was great you know he's left for a young
pilot it was exciting you see on
television Oliver had pictures of New
York well there you are right in the
middle of it was awesome as I say this
it's given me true in the early 1960s
the construction of the Pan Am
skyscraper in the heart of midtown
Manhattan offered an exciting and
unprecedented to expansion for New York
Airways situated directly above the
iconic Grand Central Terminal
a massive 59 storey office complex was a
symbolic link between the era of trains
below and the jet age above
at the time Panem was the largest and
most famous international airline to top
off their eponymous building the tower
had a unique modern amenity a rooftop
heliport for passengers connecting onto
Pan Am flights in 1965 New York Airways
partnered with Pan Am and added the
Midtown rooftop to its roots the rooftop
helipad became a widely admired cultural
landmark making its way into Hollywood
films such as the 1968 Clint Eastwood
thriller coogans bluff.the direktor
Ridley Scott has said that landing on
the Pan Am roof was the inspiration for
the futuristic sets in his sci-fi epic
Blade Runner was rounding it off it was
pretty close to 900 feet high it was
extremely challenging especially at
night in the weather thing I've ever
done except for getting shot at in
Vietnam not everyone was pleased with
the new route however the things that
bought it is the most the noise factors
and the danger it was sort of a fun I
did
yeah it's futuristic then when you think
about it you want to really a bus
overhead
populated areas in midtown Manhattan to
me that still doesn't make sense
the board ended up approving it I really
did become scared that something was
going to happen a big helicopter
bringing people in from New York's
Kennedy Airport killed five people after
landing on the roof of the 59 story of
Pan Am building in the center of town my
boss had asked me to take a quick trip
to Nashville he suggested to make it
easy use a helicopter run across town
I've took the elevator up to the Pan Am
building after a short time we started
to move up the escalator and we got
about halfway up but suddenly there was
a loud noise and we were showered with
little pieces of glass breaking
everything stopped and I went up and I
saw that the helicopter had flipped over
on its side
the thing that I most remember I can see
even today is the one body laying there
on the rooftop and it was cut up and in
the torso it was just overwhelming
loading passengers with the rotors
turning was not one of my favorite
things but apparently the thinking was
that the cost of putting on the rotor
brake to stop the rotors but still keep
the engines running ended up being a
maintenance cost that they did not want
to deal with this is the point that the
landing gear broke on the top part of
the strut and basically just rolled over
this way for passengers waiting to board
were killed instantly by the projectile
rotor blades one piece of the rotor
blade flew off the roof and smashed into
an office window on the side of the Pan
Am building
another piece fell 60 stories down to
the street killing a 29 year old woman
as she made her way home during the rush
hour commute in the wake of the disaster
the city immediately suspended all
service to the Pan Am building rooftop
the NTSB launched an investigation and
concluded that the accident was due to
high cycle fatigue propagation in other
words wear and tear as for the public
image of helicopter travel didn't do the
image any good you know and then
consequently there's no rooftop
helicopter operations in New York City
or many places around the country that I
know of maybe a couple of hospitals or
something
owing to litigation costs rising fuel
prices and declining traffic due to its
damaged reputation New York Airways went
out of business two years later in Los
Angeles San Francisco and Chicago
similar scheduled helicopter services
operated throughout the 1960s and 70s
financial issues in a series of fatal
crashes forced most of these companies
out of business as well
since the demise of New York Airways
other ventures have attempted to
replicate scheduled helicopter service
including a brief attempt in the late
1980s by Donald Trump all failed despite
the decline of scheduled service overall
helicopter traffic surged in the 1980s
due to increase private charters for
corporate travel and for tourists
sightseeing around Manhattan concerns
about noise however caused a major
backlash forcing the city to
dramatically reduce flights and heliport
access in recent years as New York
City's population traffic and wealth
have increased the demand for reliable
time-saving means of transportation is
arguably higher than ever a newcomer to
the short distance aviation market
called blade launched in 2013 is
harkening back to the Golden Age of
commercial travel powered by modern
ride-sharing technology before blade it
cost six thousand dollars to fly to the
Hamptons probably the three thousand
dollars to go to the airport we now fly
people to him to the airport for one
hundred ninety five dollars we bought
fly people to the Hamptons from five
hundred ninety five dollars it's still
expensive but we're now getting to the
point where we really almost add
ride-sharing black car pricing blade
like uber doesn't actually own any of
its vehicles instead it contracts with
helicopter charter companies and focuses
on providing a consistent customer
facing experience through a mobile app
ultimately blade faces many of the same
obstacles that the industry of space for
years the high hourly cost of helicopter
operations and the noise
but there's a new technology on the
horizon that could mitigate those issues
five six years from now is really going
to be the dawn of what we call Evita
electric vertical takeoff and landing
rotorcraft and the beauty of these
rotorcraft is that they're quiet and
they're less expensive blade along with
uber Larry Page and others are betting
on a VTOL technology to introduce a new
golden age of airborne commuting the
technology is still very primitive but
at battery capacity safety and air
traffic obstacles can be overcome
rooftop point-to-point transport could
become a reality again meanwhile 800
feet above the bustling streets of
Manhattan the heliport atop the former
Pan Am building remains closed a
forty-year-old reminder of how an
unexpected tragedy can change the course
of an industry and a city forever
[Music]
you
[Music]
you